So now that we've discussed how Donald Trump
allegedly pushed out a top vaccine, scientists
because he was refusing to promote the unproven
corona virus treatment, chloroquine that Donald
Trump liked.
I have video for you of Donald Trump, again,
being extremely triggered by CBS reporter
Wagih Giang during yesterday's White House
coronavirus press briefing.
When she asked about Dr. Bright, she referred
to Dr. Bright as having great gifts when it
comes to the work he was doing, Trump didn't
like it.
Why would a woman praised Dr. Bright and not
praised Donald Trump?
All must praise Trump, and Trump again lashed
out at her.
Check it out.
What do you say?
He has great gifts or gifts.
What?
Do you know him?
I know.
Have you reviewed?
Have you studied him?
Have you reported on him?
You said his gifts.
His gifts.
I mean, this entire career.
That doesn't mean you have gifts.
I know a lot of people that play baseball,
but they can't 1/50 anonymously that seem
like.
No, no.
You talk about his great gifts.
This actually seems pathological with Trump
and women who do not back down from him.
Trump seems like a guy I've said before.
Trump doesn't seem to have meaningful.
Relationships with women.
He doesn't seem to have a meaningful relationship
with Melania.
What we know of his past marriages don't suggest
meaningful relationships.
What we know about his past mistresses and
six-figure payoffs don't suggest does not
suggest meaningful relationships with women.
There seems to be an insecurity with Trump,
where he is immediately threatened and triggered
by women who are actually assertive and confident,
like with he Yang, and who have the potential
to make Donald Trump look really bad, which
she often does quite effortlessly, I must
say.
So what's going on here is very clear.
She didn't praise Trump.
She's not sucking up to Trump the way he thinks
women are supposed to do.
And she has the audacity to praise another
man.
It's very difficult for Trump to handle as
the alpha male that he claims to be.
And remember that this is the same reporter
that was told by Donald Trump a few days ago.
Hey, take it easy.
Take it easy.
Relax.
Lower your voice.
Who do you work for?
And she is so getting under his skin.
Here is Trump pointing to her and saying she
wasn't called on during yesterday's press
briefing.
There's this constant level of triggered this
that we see in Donald Trump as a result of
her presence there.
Is that accurate?
You are on both sides.
We talked about this yesterday.
Baby sitter Trump laying down the law on CBS.
Is Wagih a Giang, but not on anybody else
for a while.
It was CNN's Jim Acosta that was regularly
firing Trump up.
But Trump now seems to have become kind of
comfortable with the adversarial relationship.
He knows.
Jim Acosta will ask an adversarial question.
He kind of seems to relish and be comfortable
with mixing it up with Jim Acosta.
It is very different with CBS is Wagih Giang.
Trump does not seem to relish the tough questions
from her.
He seems visibly uncomfortable.
He is very easily triggered by her every question
and statement and every time she speaks up,
seemingly very bothersome to Donald Trump.
And I have to tell you, I absolutely love
it